companies like Google and Facebook are
factory farms for human beings that's
how they make their money they make
their money by tracking everything that
you do by profiling you and then
monetizing that by manipulating your
behavior with this intimate insight
we're not sleepwalking into some sort of
dystopia we're there my name is Errol
balkon and I'm a cyborg rights activist
when you go on to Facebook Instant
Messenger and you know your messaging
your friend you might think that you're
in a room together and only you two can
hear each other that's not the case now
for you it might be you feel that you
have nothing to hide you don't care if
Google has your data you might start to
care the next time you go to renew your
insurance and your premiums double and
then when you ask them why I have my
premiums doubled they say well you're
smart fridge told us what you're eating
now that might be when you start to care
if you have a lot of privilege for other
people it's a life or death issue people
who do care might be for example people
who are gay but live in a country in
which it is illegal to be gay and
Facebook knows that they're gay based on
their likes now this is a problem for
them
shoshanna's Zubov from Harvard Business
School calls the system that we live
under surveillance capitalism
surveillance capitalism is the feedback
loop between surveillance and capitalism
capitalism is about the accumulation of
wealth now what happens when that
accumulated wealth and the people who
have that wealth and power then invests
that wealth in surveillance devices
which allow them to gather information
about all of us which in turn allows
them to manipulate our behavior which in
turn makes them more money and
reinforces this feedback loop well
that's the pronounced capitalism we have
to regulate the abuses of the
surveillance capitalists and we have to
replace them with ethical alternatives
why don't we start thinking about
funding those technologies from the
Commons for the common good unless we
change how technology is funded today we
can't fix this problem because this is
not a technology problem if we want a
different society if we want different
ideologies amplified then we need to
fund them differently we need to build
them differently and then we have a
chance of a progressive future